okay so I think I have a handle and
optimizing HTML and CSS so are we moving
on to the render tree almost we haven't
really talked about JavaScript and
obviously that's an important step so
let's take a look at that hmm okay well
let me guess
minify it compress it and catch it yep
all of those are good strategies but for
JavaScript you may have seen P speed
insights also complain about parser
blocking scripts let's take a look at
what that means and how we can optimize
it I've extended our hello world page
with a simple inline script at the
bottom let's walk through it first of
all we reach into the DOM and look for
the first span element which as you can
see contains the web performance text
next we modify the Dom element by
changing its inner text and also
changing its CSS properties seems simple
enough yeah this shows that JavaScript
can manipulate both the Dom and the CSS
object model it's a very powerful tool
and it gets a bit more interesting from
here next we create a new div element
set its text content CSS color property
and append it to the page let's try to
load this page on our phone notice that
the text now says hello interactive
students instead of hello web
performance students and we also have
our new element right below it right as
expected so is there anything here we
can do to optimize performance
definitely optimizing javascript could
be an entire course but in this
particular example it's not really the
code but how its included on the page
let's take a step back and think about
how the browser would go about building
this page